[Music]
this unification has however already
occurred in principle and that too in
religion in the return of picture
thinking into self-consciousness but not
according to the proper form for the
religious aspect is the aspect of the in
itself which stands over against the
movement of self-consciousness
consequently the unification belongs to
this other aspect which in the contrast
of the two sides is the aspect of
reflection into self and therefore the
one that contains both its own self and
its opposite and not only implicitly or
in a universal sense but explicitly or
in a developed and differentiated way
the content as well as the other aspect
of self-conscious spirit so far as it is
the other aspect has been exhibited and
is before us in its completeness
the unification that is still lacking is
the simple Unity of the notion the
notion too is itself already present on
the side of self-consciousness but as it
has come before us thus far it has to be
a particular Shape Of Consciousness like
all the other moments it is therefore
that aspect of the shape of self-assured
spirit that abides within its notion and
was called the Beautiful Soul the
beautiful soul is its own knowledge of
itself and it's pure transparent Unity
the self-consciousness that knows this
pure knowledge of pure inwardness as
spirit
it is not only the intuition of the
Divine but the divine's intuition of
itself since this notion holds itself
firmly opposed to its realization it is
the one-sided shape which we saw vanish
Into Thin Air but also positively
externalize itself and move onward
through this realization the object-less
self-consciousness ceases to cling to
the determinateness of the notion as
against its fulfillment its
self-consciousness gains the form of
universality and what remains to it is
its true notion or the notion that has
attained its realization it is the
notion in its truth that is in unity
with its externalization it is the
knowing of pure knowledge not as an
abstract Essence such as duty is but of
knowledge as an essential being which is
this knowledge this pure
self-consciousness which is therefore at
the same time a genuine object for the
notion is the self that is for itself
paragraph 795 appears to pick up right
where its previous paragraph 794 left
off by talking about unification for
Eine going but what we're going to get
here is so typical of Hegel and we're
coming to a close so this is very
important in how he's doing this we get
a resolution of sorts in one paragraph
and then Hegel kind of takes it back in
the next paragraph demonstrating to us
showing to us that something isn't as
completely worked out as it was
presented as being and this is very
normal in in the dialectical process
isn't it it's very normal in real life
ordinary life that we think that
something is completely finished and
then we find oh no there's all sorts of
other stuff that has to be done now why
is this this particularly important
because it's going to be reiterating
something that we saw at the end of the
big religion section which is that
we have now realized
um what it is that representation for
shallowing brings to the table
but we need to in some way move Beyond
it and that's already happening in the
end of the religion section and it takes
a lot of work to do that and now that's
going to be reiterated here in this
paragraph part of the absolute knowing
section how do we actually get to
Absolute knowing well we got to pass
through that what happened in religion
it doesn't mean we have to become
religious Believers or anything as a
matter of fact
what we're doing as phenomenologists
following along with Hegel is in some
respects leaving behind what other
people have done as the work for us
throughout the centuries and which is
being sort of summarized and sub-bladed
here so let's start at the start it
invokes this unification for Heineken
and it says it is already occurred in
principle anzi it's occurred in itself
in some way and that too in religion in
the return of
picture thinking into self-consciousness
now notice what is being said here it
happened in religion but it didn't
happen just at any old point in religion
it happened when religion the people
engaging in that religion in the
religious community through their
narratives became aware of the
limitations of picture thinking of four
stellen representation and brought that
back into
self-consciousness now what would this
mean
we can imagine that part of this is you
know the function of critical
scholarship people saying well wait a
second I am distanced from that event
that I can take as contemporary uh
happening uh Millennia ago you know
we're talking about Christianity so we
could call it the Christ event or
Christ's sequence of events that are
narrated how am I going to understand my
own relation to these representations
how do I understand our relationship in
the present to that so he goes on and he
says this happened in principle but not
according to the proper form and we're
going to see a contrast throughout this
paragraph between form and content in
halt which he talks about as well so
we've got one side here right the
unification in religion not just of
religion and then we have that of
self-conscious just Spirit right so he
says not according to the proper form
the religious aspect is the aspect of
the in itself the anzique which stands
over against the movement of
self-consciousness how do we get
self-consciousness in its full extent
which we saw introduce Way Way Back in
the self-consciousness section but
undeveloped there or rather in lesser
stages of development so he says
consequently the unification
belongs to this other aspect which in
the contrast of the two sides now what
are the two sides this is where we have
to go back to the previous paragraph
that is a reference to the religious
spirit on one side and conscious
Consciousness itself as such on the
other side
and we saw that there's like a dual
aspect in both parts of these right so
um the unification that's been you know
happening at the end of it where we get
the in and for itself
um now it's bringing in another aspect
the aspect of reflection into self
therefore the one that contains both its
own self and its opposite now Hegel
actually uses the term gaganzots here
and uh the opposite gagan tile is the
opposed the
contradictory side of this so what we
have here is the side of what he's going
to call self-conscious Spirits in just a
bit right the content as well as the
other aspect of self-conscious spirit
this involves reflection into self and
even more importantly it contains and
Hell it you know holds on to but at a
kind of distance its own self Zeke
what it is how it understands itself
because it is self-conscious and it's
opposite now the opposite of
self-consciousness is that one single
thing is that just an abstraction or
does that
signify
plural opposites I mean it could be
another self-consciousness but we could
also think of it as
what it is that it is conscious of right
and so there's there's a complex
reflection going on here it's not just
well it's got its own self over here and
it's opposite that it's contradictory to
it's uh intersecting with it it's
connected with it it's incorporating
that might be another nice way to
translate and health there incorporates
that so he goes on
and he says that it does it contains
both its own self and its opposite not
only implicitly or in a universal sense
this is very important here because
in the previous paragraph We saw that
part of what you know part of what
religion brings to the table is vehicle
actuality and we we definitely want as
much of that as we can get because there
is a tendency for the dialectic in Hagel
to get a little abstract right and at
the same time one of the points that
Hegel hammers home over and over and
over again is that no actuality no home
for spirit Spirit is not just actuality
the world as we know it or our own you
know characters and bodies and histories
as we know it or our relations to other
people
but that's really
intrinsic to it and you know this is one
of the things I think is actually a good
point about Hegel which sometimes gets
lost on Hazel's own part and definitely
by other interpreters all right
digression over back to this so
explicitly
um not only implicitly or in a universal
sense but explicitly and in a developed
and differentiated a
um you know divided up way so so he goes
on and he says the content as well as
the other aspect of self-conscious
Spirit
insofar as it is the other aspect has
been exhibited it's been shown to us
it's been brought before us and is
before us it's at hand for Honda right
uh in
um
uh it's completeness
this is really important because
we can have something like an ocean or a
concept right a begraph
but it needs to be completed it needs to
be developed it needs to be
differentiated and then a Unity needs to
be given to it Unity reconciliation
however we want to think about this and
so this is you know the ebb and flow of
the dialectic in motion here in this
last section
notice too that he's used this term
content in health right so we've got
content we have form and how are we
going to bring them together so then he
says
um
the unification that is still lacking
is the simple Unity of the notion or the
concept the begrif right the on einfaka
simple uh literally like one fold well
that would be einfalta sorry so a simple
einheit Unity right and there's a
difference here between unification and
something that is a Unity desperate of
the concept and so all of this is not
yet where it should be how are we going
to get it there well
here's where Hegel takes an interesting
turn back out of the religion section
back into the spirit section
so it sounds pretty good at first
the notion two is already present on the
side of self-consciousness but as it has
come before us thus far
it has to be a particular Shape Of
Consciousness like all the other moments
and as I was rereading that again you
know that paragraph As I do as I prepare
for these things
um I was like yeah okay you know what
he's saying there is that absolute
knowing has to be a shape of
Consciousness and I think in a certain
sense it it does right because it is
part of this vast process to be a
determinate Shape Of Consciousness means
being located
in not necessarily a particular time
like oh it's happening at 12 36 or
something like that in this location but
you can think of it as extending itself
in space and time and in culture and
then you know being available to us
through this this work later on
so you know having a per a particular
besundra Shape Of Consciousness
um that's you know kind of good what
shape of Consciousness is he going to
bring up here
um well let's read on
says as it has come before us thus far
it has to be a particular Shape Of
Consciousness like all the other moments
it is therefore
that aspect of the shape of self-assured
spirit so now we're going back into the
spirit section towards the end of it of
course right
that abides within its notion that
sounds pretty good it it rests it it
stays it has a location
metaphorically within its concept
the concept
and was called the Beautiful Soul
right now if you call somebody a
beautiful soul within the hegelian
jargon that's typically not a good thing
and we should remind ourselves well what
were the characteristics of the
Beautiful Soul this part of the
phenomenology that I think many people
do know it's it we could say it's part
of the mythology of the phenomenology
right we've got the Master Slave
dialectic we've got sense certainty
we've got the oh so difficult uh force
in the understanding and laws and worlds
and stuff like that we've got the
Antigone section we've got uh you know
the absolute freedom and the terror
we've got all these interesting things
going on and the Beautiful Soul is part
of that Pantheon of hegelian
um shapes of consciousness
so the beautiful soul is a person in
whom there's this you know realization
of of uh what the hegelian dialectic has
been trying to elaborate for us but they
don't do anything right they are so to
speak
um detached they you know they might
whine about how things are but they they
don't actually take any action to change
the situation and so why is Hegel
bringing up the Beautiful Soul here well
he tells us the beautiful soul is its
own knowledge of itself in its pure
transparent Unity the self-consciousness
that knows this pure knowledge of pure
inwardness as spirit so when he says
that that doesn't sound like anything
new being it on the table right the
beautiful soul is
you know individualized but it's it's
rather abstract in part because it
refuses
any sort of besmirching itself any sort
of dirtying itself by actually doing
something within the world of reality or
actuality so you know another word for a
beautiful soul that we sometimes use
here in the present is a poser right a
poser is somebody who takes a stance
about something now you know we we use
this uh back when I was in high school
actually even Middle School to high
school about uh I used to skateboard we
used it of other skateboarders that
would often have you know a very
beautiful deck and all sorts of
equipment and the right hat and stuff
like that and talk the lingo but didn't
actually skate much in part because they
didn't want to take the chance of
wearing their wheels down or making
their deck look bad or possibly you know
tearing up their their artfully arranged
genes and you know we've used this in
many other Frameworks as well but you
get the idea right it's somebody who is
committed in principle on Zeke
but when it comes to actually doing
anything being in a world they they
withdraw from that they take a stance
but they're taking a stance costs them
absolutely nothing but now notice what
Hagel says next which I think is adding
something new to the to the shape of the
Beautiful Soul
he tells us that it namely the the
Beautiful Soul the self-consciousness
that knows the pure knowledge of pure
inwardness of spirit is not only the
intuition of the Divine and here he uses
anshalong right so it's not intuition
like uh woo-woo feeling feeling or
something like that but it's it's like a
straightforward grasp of something right
and it could be shared with with others
foreign
the god-like the of the Gods kind of
thing what it is that matters most right
so it's an intuition of the Divine
but it's also the divines intuition of
itself
of itself
um and notice that there's like a sort
of intensification here so it already on
showing is intuition of itself
um so it's like a doubled intuition of
itself or intuition that's folded into
itself it happens through the Beautiful
Soul the beautiful soul is the one if we
want to use some other language who
grasps the true The Good the beautiful
and remains within that not like all of
us you know uh practitioners who are
caught up within contradictions and
stuff like that
um now is is this how God the divine
understands itself and is understood I
mean I think this is where we actually
do see
religion and what has been achieved
through the as he says the return of
picture thinking into itself
picture thinking is of the Divine Right
so this is a mode in which the Divine
can be apprehended
whatever the Divine happens to be right
so he goes on and he says um
since the notion
holds itself
firmly opposed to its realization so
this is quite interesting right uh the
notion here in the beautiful soul is
um being opposed to its own realization
it is the one-sided shape which we saw
vanish Into Thin Air but
where do we go from the Beautiful Soul
we don't just stay in that
it's positively
externalizes now Miller here is using
verbs where Hegel uses uh nouns that are
actually
action nouns we could say so
externalizes there is a externalization
or alienation of itself
um and uh it moves onward right so here
we go yeah moves onward and that is Fort
bavague so bevegoing is movement
shifting right fought onward works
really great so it's not the Beautiful
Soul that does that because it ceases
being the beautiful soul in doing that
but it is the person
who at first is in the Beautiful Soul or
perhaps is confronted by the beautiful
soul and says this can't be it there's
got to be more going on and it has to be
within a
realization now notice that he doesn't
use something like vehicle he uses
wrong which means to become real to
become part of this this world that
we're within and he's going to tell us a
few things about this
so he goes on and he says
through this realization the objectless
self-consciousness of the beautiful soul
is ceases to cling to the
determinateness of the notion as against
its fulfillment so you know it's sort of
like well you can have one but you can't
have the other and then hegel's saying
well of course you can have both you
know why not uh it's self-consciousness
gains the form of universality and what
remains to it is its true notion so we
have notion at the start or concept and
then we have true notion what's what's
the difference between these well this
is alphabon right this is where
something is being carried forward and
the detritus the stuff that we don't
need is being left behind and we're
getting the gold instead of the other
stuff that has to be thrown away or
we're getting the wheat that we can eat
instead of the chaff or pick whatever
other model you want for this selection
process that is caring for what's really
essential to this self-consciousness in
doing so the self-consciousness is
becoming Universal not in the sense of
like my own individual
self-consciousness becomes everybody in
the world
but I'm sort of standing in for as if I
am that is if I bear that responsibility
I carry that weight so good good points
there
um it's self-consciousness gains a form
of universality what remains to it is
its true notion or the notion
once again that has attained its
realization
and now notice what he's going to say
about this notion that has attained its
realization
it is the notion in its truth
right or the concept in its truth what
is truth for Hegel it's not just
corresponding to a reality that we
happen to grasp it is also the coherence
the development some things can be more
true because they are better well
developed and their contradictions have
been worked through whereas other things
may be less true so this is the concept
in not in truth but in its truth truth
becomes something that belongs
to the concept something that pertains
to the concept and he goes on and says
in unity
with its externalization it's an awesome
so this isn't just a notion in our heads
or out there in our discourse
It Is Us
we are a vital part of that notion we
are the ones grasping it we are also the
self-consciousnesses that are the object
of that notion and truth you could say
so he goes on and he tells us
what this is
it is the knowing of pure knowledge okay
now absolute knowing probably should be
about the knowing of pure knowledge
right there's a reflexivity there it's
knowing of knowledge it's pure we've
gotten rid of all the other stuff that
we didn't actually need and it's
contained in the previous pages but then
he says not as an abstract Essence that
is a vision uh right that's abstract and
notice the uh example that he uses there
as duty is
now when is Duty abstract I mean that
seems like something very specific I've
got my duties you got your duties
flicked and right
um Hegel spent a lot of time analyzing
the very complex often contradictory
developmental concept of Duty especially
in the spirit section right with the
morality stuff but looking at Human
Action and how it can never be complete
and exactly what it's supposed to be
okay there's all of that going on so why
is he talking about Duty here well
because Duty can become something
abstract and what does he say instead
knowledge
as an essential being again using the
term vasen there
so a different kind of vase and a
different kind of essence which is this
knowledge
it's being once again
particularized it's it's being specified
it's being rooted in its reality uh this
knowledge this pure self-consciousness
which is therefore at the same time a
genuine object a gegenstein something
that can be looked at we can look at our
own
self-consciousness and we can decide
whether it's pure or not and then he
says he concludes with for the notion is
the self that is for itself right so the
notion the the because this Living
Concept
that we're supposed to you know grasp in
this section is the self that is for
itself as opposed to being in itself and
you might say well what's going on here
we finished up the previous paragraph by
attaining to something that wasn't just
for itself as opposed to in itself it
was in and for itself where did that go
well you know like I said oftentimes
Hegel gives and then takes back and what
he's going to give back is going to be a
little bit more complex and you know
worked through so you know some pretty
interesting stage setting happening here
and now you know if the previous
paragraphs
were looking ahead but also a lot of
looking back to the previous shapes of
Consciousness and saying well what what
have we been doing up into absolute
knowing through the rest of this work in
this paragraph we're now turning again
and we're looking at where we're
supposed to be
headed
and that's you know what we're going to
be doing through the rest of this
section we've really only got I mean you
know it's not just a few paragraphs
right uh we're we're in we just finished
up with
795 and the whole thing ends at 808 so
we've got you know 12 13 paragraphs yet
to go but we're now turning in I won't
say the right direction because they're
all the right directions but in one
that's going to lead us to this positive
movement forward through what's left of
the dialectic of the phenomenology